Do you have any other greens, powders, suggestions that don't have stevia?
Well, so, yes, there are some other greens, powders that we have on the store that don't have stevia.
So, the garden of life has some greens, powders.
New Medica has greens, powders.
There's a natural greens for biotics.
And what I suggest about those, the, I've, you know, personally, it's just a part of it's a matter of taste.
We've had people try different greens and they, they like them better than the greens first.
First and, and that's great, as long as they're a good balanced greens.
The, the only issue that I have with some green powders that are out there is that they aren't all just ground food.
You mean, they're not just all full food, they are often they put in some synthetic nutrients, they might put in extra, you know, metal tetrahedral folate things like that because they think they're trying to make it just like a multiple.
There is a
roll greens by, I think it's neutral neutral, neutral, ecology or something like that.
That we do have on the store that is organic greens and I don't think that one has stevia to I've not tried them so you could try that one.
That's probably the closest to the greens first as far as its contents goes.
But I've not tried it, you better come make some different greens shakes.
But I'm not so keen on those they use whatever is the natural flavorings I'm always suspicious that there's, you know, chemicals are that.
A lot of sodium glutamate or something like that to make them taste better and yes, some of the companies do play those games on some types of some product.